all five of us yeah you heard that right
the Backstreet Boys are reuniting Nick
Carter confirmed to et at the dead seven
premiere in Los Angeles that the group
is ready to head to Las Vegas gotta set
the record straight
there's two rumors one that you guys are
eyeing a residency in Las Vegas
well the residency thing actually we we
have a deal with Live Nation which is
the touring company and we just signed a
nine show deal to to do sort of like a
test run in in Vegas with the residency
so that's definitely gonna happen but
we're gonna do a trial run first Kevin
Richardson came out to support his
bandmate at the premiere he exclusively
revealed to ET the new music is on the
way and the reunion is happening soon
we're gonna do a little test run
probably end of this year beginning of
next year see how it goes but we're
definitely in the studio recording a
brand new album we're gonna do a world
tour first it would definitely have to
be a very big and spectacular show and
thankfully we have a good catalog so we
could perform all of our hits and that
could take up a lot of the show
it's twenty years almost since the first
Backstreet Boys album came out may 1996
anything that you want to say about that
album and here fans we love you guys out
there thank you so much and for giving
us a great life and hopefully we could
do the same back by continuing to
entertain you
you